we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P one of the things we've
heard for a long time now is that if
they can arrest trump it could happen to
you here's a version of that via
voicemail that's kind of tongue-in-cheek
David
I am fleeing Florida because
Trump has been arrested and if he can be
arrested than any of the rest of us can
be arrested so I'm really concerned for
my well-being and the well-being of my
machines you know my car my coffee
machine so I'm just really trying to get
out of here yep but in all seriousness
I'm honeymooning to Montreal in the
summer and I wanted to hear some
suggestions for where I should go to eat
okay for Montreal suggestions maybe call
in I don't want to bore the audience
with that right now but I do want to
address this thing that they've been
saying if they can do this to Trump they
can do this to anyone they do it to
anyone all the time we know that they
can do it to anyone it's not like up
until yesterday we thought wow
once they cross the Rubicon of arresting
a president then they might arrest just
random antibodies now we knew that in
fact the problem all along was there is
this belief that there is a two-tier
justice system and I believe that that
is accurate it's not Republicans and
Democrats it's the wealthy
and everybody else and even yesterday
Donald Trump was able to negotiate no
handcuffs no mug shot it's a private
entrance all these different things so
we already knew it could happen to
anyone the question now of course is
can you actually hold the president
accountable or is this all going to
evaporate and if it does of course the
right will say it's because the charges
were bogus to begin with and we'll have
that discussion but we knew it could
happen to anyone we now know that at
least theoretically even former
presidents aren't Above the Law that's a
good thing to know if you are an
American we have a fantastic bonus show
for you today a Finland joins NATO and
this is a major shift I'll talk about my
time in Finland and there's so many
interesting things to talk about
secondly not only could anti-wokism
backfire on Republicans their obsession
with transgender issues could backfire
as well we'll talk about new polling
that suggests why and yes Marianne
Williamson making polling gains against
Joe Biden many of you said David because
you don't support Marianne you're not
going to cover her polling search I am
going to cover her polling search on
today's bonus show sign up at joinpakman
com get instant access and you can use
the coupon code indicted
or you can use the coupon code indicated
it's your choice whichever you prefer